greetings in podcast Ville let's get the
[ __ ] bong head going together your
speedy toast models out of the way there
you go
it's Monday the 24th of February who the
[ __ ] do you think you're dealing with
the Church of what's happening now is
brought to you by unless you've been
living under a rock I hope you heard
about me on these they're going for the
total undie domination if you look at my
underwear drawer
it's all me undies and they're not gonna
stop til they get every pocket listener
to start wearing them I've been slinging
their [ __ ] panties for years
[ __ ] my drawers are [ __ ]
packed with them and I'll tell you what
they keep your balls clean nice smelling
I don't know what it does I don't know
what's in on me undies it's the fabric
it's the micro Modell fabric it keeps
that whole area dry there's some nights
11:00 11:30 I do a little [ __ ] nut
test
i scratch might take a little whiff
voila I mean it ain't [ __ ] an incense
but I ain't killing nobody either you're
them saying listen to me go to me up
seize right now calm and look at the
great selection underway as they got
matching underwear [ __ ] socks
listen just start with the [ __ ]
underwear you're gonna be [ __ ] happy
go to me on these calm right now / Joey
and get 15% off and free shipping on
your first [ __ ] purchase plus
you get the me on these hundred percent
satisfaction guarantee here and who's
better than them nobody go to me on
these today's guest is my main man the
[ __ ] ultimate New Yorker mr. Sam
Morrell great to have your nation of me
on there what's up my brother
this is great I use I use one of those
CBD bath bombs the other night man
[ __ ] I don't take bath but I get back
you do the road all the time you get
back problems and [ __ ] you know so it's
really weird so I lift on Mondays and
Thursdays and both those women [ __ ]
break my
back and I'll go home and do some
downward dogs or whatever I'm good yeah
if I go to that coffee shop I sit there
and I try to write yeah hubba-wha days
that's the worst my back gets really
yeah me too it destroys my back nice is
my back I can go lift a [ __ ] house
for an hour in the next day yeah I got a
little back pain and your muscles floor
well it's not when I sit there it just
kills me I put a timer on it yeah you
got an hour and 15 I got one of those
half balls I said on it was half ball so
it forces you to kind of sit up I was
that working I don't I'm still a weak
Jew I still have like the weak frame of
just like the I I'm not it's I don't
think it's I think it's just another
thing that makes you feel better but
it's not really helping you've been on
fire little you've been doing really
well thank you miss oh no can't feel it
it's you know I mean you're in a [ __ ]
great movie Joker
thank you you're on some Showtime show
so yeah oh yeah yeah little things I
hate comics really and I do the same
yeah well we really don't grasp what
we're doing were laying down little
things it's hard to feel it it's hard to
feel the good how was the reaction to
you being in the Joker it's probably the
most messages I've ever gotten in my
life because for some reason Todd
Phillips just kept my real name in the
movie so after I get off stage that the
host goes one more time for Sam Morrell
so everyone's like wait what
so I like childhood friends be like you
were in the [ __ ] Joker I didn't tell
anyone I was in it because I would I was
just doing stand-up so like why would
they keep me and you know I was shooting
it all day and it's a real crowd so I'm
doing a different set every take because
I didn't want I don't want to have to
have them fake laugh so it's like let me
do real a new joke every take so they're
actually laughing and then Chris Redd is
hosting a comic Chris read so he's
hosting so he's getting so annoyed
because he I get to do new bits every
take and he just he's just like one more
time for Sam morale that's his only line
is just to say my name and then he
introduces the Joker on stage who bombs
so
it was Sammy I was like well yeah I get
the dude material but you're gonna make
the movie and I'm not so I didn't tell
anyone I was in it cuz I just assumed
they were gonna cut me and boom there
you are they did yeah they don't you
don't really see my face you just hear
me tell a joke but it was like for that
that's my joke that's cool did you go to
the premiere no no no I didn't get
invited for me inviting the cast crew no
I have such a minor part it doesn't
matter that's that's crazy yeah how did
you cast apart Todd Phillips called me
the director and he just said like your
standup because you're not like he said
something like long as you're not cutesy
on stage you feel like very you you're
just like I think you're just you on
stage and I appreciate that it's under
the tape on Ethan no I didn't I think
called John a [ __ ] blue yeah that's a
knockout I think my I think my I think
they asked for an agency for a bunch of
tapes and he came across mine he said I
like this guy good so is me and Gary
Coleman that he liked gether he was in
it mark Moran's oh yeah Bryan Callen was
in it right yeah Greer Barnes a lot of
comics pretty cool that Todd Phillips
does that it's weird how the business
has changed if you're in it like you
could have been a [ __ ] you would
let's say you would have had a half-hour
on Comedy Central yeah you pop a [ __ ]
movie role yeah 30 years ago you start
selling out every weekend yeah I did a
half-hour no one can find it cuz it's on
Comedy Central I did an hour nobody can
find it cuz it's done Comedy Central and
then you know now this one they they put
on YouTube so people can find it you
know it was so really year ago I bumped
into some guy because I'm not doing a
podcast lame or like old why not he goes
on cuz I tried it for two years I didn't
saw any more technics
because so you did the podcast with
tickets in mind right
you weren't just doing it to add to your
you know your arsenal things right
English yeah I just wanted to give it a
shot by my mom it's so weird I felt
about it because I feel that everything
you do adds to your arsenal that little
part ten years from now
might become something completely weird
and thirty years from now when you're
broke
and they're doing Joker conventions and
you're showing up and you want your Sam
around and that was a picture and they
you know they it always comes back like
it's so weird how we look at minor
things you know I have a million things
out there TV shows yeah I brought in a
box of mail
I delivered something somebody signed
you know but now looking back I was just
getting stronger yeah and stronger and
stronger there's a million things well
that's a great attitude and then I got
two lines and then for a year I did I
would book movies and they were always
one day what the [ __ ] yeah I'm one day
joke that's it and they would either be
the first scene with their at its
rolling through it yeah well the last
scene weather credit scrolling through
it I did like a year of those yeah then
I started booking to two days on a film
all right we're getting some way hills
and kids but I booked like 11 on one I
was like okay now but it's like everyone
counts towards something yeah you're
just you also just getting better and
more comfortable in your own skin I
think each thing that like like I'm
doing Conan on Tuesday and it's my it's
my sixth time on Conan and I'm kind of
like yeah I think about each of those
times and the first time I was so
nervous and the second time I was like
[ __ ] it I'm gonna have a couple scotches
before I go on I deserve I think I'm
like I think I can handle this and then
each time I just kind of like I used to
run them so hard every set like it meant
like and they still mean a lot to me
each set means something to me but but
they're just like I don't really I'm
just not nervous I'm just like well I am
I prepare I I'd send my nature to
prepare for the set so I'm gonna prepare
but I'm not I'm gonna do everything I
can do don't don't go don't kill
yourself I used to kill myself over it
28 years I just don't kill them myself
yeah I just figured out that you work
you're right the material is there yeah
deliver it do the best you can know what
you're gonna go up there and say no
you're gonna end with yeah and just go
with specials on the mad analyze every
word
and for no reason no you should analyze
every word okay but I think I know what
you said don't kill yourself but yeah
like I do analyze it but what a special
round that's fair and that's not right
you know the other night I was watching
Creed - yeah you know it's on TV Friday
night
my daughter's running around whatever
and there was just everyone loves to
versus the wall movies they're not
Academy Award winners but he always says
one thing in those movies and the kid
was saying something the black kid
Michael B Jordan Michael Jordan
tremendous he's awesome and he goes you
know what you're thinking too much just
say was kept in your heart and that's
what stand that you know we were talking
about Walt Frazier earlier before the
podcast and I you know the legendary
Nick and he always says when players are
shooting badly he always goes he's
aiming his shot and that applies to
stand up your you aiming your shot means
you're thinking you know you got to
trust a muscle memory did you practice
if you practice you don't you don't have
to that you just you just do it you know
the same with stand-up you practice much
you practice then you got to like free
yourself a little and be you like you
were though you're funny that's why
you're there you know what I mean so if
you write the jokes and you focus on the
jokes be free don't be it's almost like
you're too tight sometimes like for
specials I was depending too much on
what was on the paper right and I
wouldn't break away from them that's not
who I am
right that's not who I am I think you
need to do like you need to do like
shows you need your like a full weekend
I came a cry enjoy doing the joke and
then somewhere sometimes taking it
somewhere else
yeah and taking it to a story and then
coming back that joke and then going
somewhere else yeah with specials I
thought was too scripted it was a TV
show I couldn't have a dull moment in my
head I had a shade dull moments it's
nothing like digging yourself out of all
there's nothing like banging them out
and then somewhere at the 12-minute mark
dying for a minute or two and then
digging your way out all and closing it
out with a [ __ ] bubble you know
like an uncomfortable moment in this
other why I like haven't come to my
moment and every time I do it yeah I
take every spot seriously and I'm really
good with the economy of words yeah I
understand the economy of words I
understand when I go home and listen til
I got [ __ ] recording and that I
shouldn't have said that word and that
word belongs here I like all that stuff
you you're a phenomenal writer thank you
I'm not a writer like you you but you
are a writer you're storyteller
right or but you told a story on re show
once that was so moving and funny you
know it was about I think was a I'm
trying to remember these extra but it
was about an older woman in your life
yeah it was incredible I'm WOM with
friends yeah it was incredible and it
was so I mean you have the ability to
connect that is uh it was such a it was
heavy I love a story that's funny but
also as like [ __ ] that like that kind of
affected me I think that sometimes
comedy comes with a heavy dose and and
you don't see it I like breaking down
calmly and a heavy dose I want to target
you strength we're talking my Sylvester
Stallone yeah he tugs at your heart
every movie that he does I didn't see
the second Cree but the first one the
whole cancer plot he I was like that was
a [ __ ] beautifully hugs at your heart
every movie he does I just watched the
last Rambo
I was bored one Friday there's a great
movie theater in North Hollywood they're
like $8 thickets and I'm watching them
and I'm like everything he does like he
always leaves you with something all
right
you know it's not I know he's [ __ ] 64
and even he knows he's 70 in that movie
he's not doing anything
Tom and he's not trying to be John wick
he you know he did different things to
[ __ ] him up and he outwitted them but
whatever I don't know how the [ __ ] we
got talking Sylvester Stallone you're a
great writer that's that means you sit
down every day I try to I try to sit
down every day and I've been bad lately
but I usually have like a routine I'll
try to just you know go to the coffee
shop I'll take a walk I'll do I'll do
whatever I can do I
in assets like you were just saying I
hear sometimes I'll hear a word I'm like
all that that could like go in this
direction I can kind of come back you
know to the bit so yeah I think uni is
funny he brought up still long because
he really I I heard I don't know this I
think that it's true that with rocky
they told him not to be rocky right and
they're like we'll give you way more
money if you're just out of the movie
and we cast a movie star and it's like
who the [ __ ] else could you picture is
rocky now the if you even knew the
choices that they were looking who are
they looking at Burt rebel Dustin
Hoffman no it was Burt Reynolds somebody
else but the main guy they were looking
at was who the guy that was married to
Farrah Fawcett Wow Ryan O'Neal that
would have been a [ __ ] shame it was
like yeah it was like it's now weird
Robert Redford
but that first choice was far from who
and then what people all know is a rocky
got shot like Rocky was one of those
movies that they called you and they
said you're in it but something happened
along the way with the money and then
they called back and said shooting
starts next week since people are like I
already booked a job yeah it's like
Apollo Creed Mickey and Paulie were
booked the Friday before the Monday oh
my god like something [ __ ] outrageous
something just and you don't know that
phone call changes the course your
career isn't that crazy yeah like it was
supposed to be Ken Norton up to that
weekend something happen to Ken Norton
Wow so that guy had a play Creed I don't
know who the original Mickey was I don't
really know just little stories like the
hand did I like like that scene he does
when he goes and sees the shorts he goes
to the right before he moves in Adrian
goes to the spectrum and he tells the do
a my shorts I don't remember the [ __ ]
color my shorts are red with a boot the
poster these are blue with a red rim
right that takes a public
because it really doesn't matter son
does it and that just tapped into his
[ __ ] South Philly side and he goes
back and he wakes her up a thousand I
can't [ __ ] do that they had to do
that one take this there were a lot of
felt Wow
so next time you see Sylvester Stallone
you want to make you a little [ __ ]
stupid remark state most people make
think about somebody telling you we got
one shot left yeah it's got to be
perfect
I'm a fan I'm I think you hear the rocky
music it's like hearing the Star Wars
music that's like when I said when they
remade Creed and I just heard the music
I was like [ __ ] there's like I'm there's
like an American mythology let your like
taps into your heart a little bit make
it you can't you made a stone you're an
[ __ ] if you feel nothing it's because
it's the best music it's it changes
America I'm never going to that movie
theater the whole movie theater that was
one of those movies I saw him you see
them Jersey and I've had a movie theater
called a cinema I'll sell him I was like
human neighborhood and [ __ ] the hope
the whole place is on their feet no
place yeah there were two movies I seen
in that happy that the whole place were
on their feet at the end
rocky and and Birth of a Nation left 200
kids Yellin I mean she can main machine
you know that the I she's had to come
out pop war was getting throw gold
[ __ ] nuts but that was a different era
you know I saw Rambo Duke I'm washing
tonight's damn well it's 780th on the
corner nice this is like a it's like a
big cross street and they used to be a
black movie theater there okay I went to
a vegan restaurant there recently
yeah and funny is yeah let's change but
there was a movie theater there and
there was two of them on that block yeah
there was one on the corner that showed
modern movies and if you walk down a
little bit there was one that was two
movies for five bucks smelt like sperm
people just wanted any afternoons to
keep warm and jerk off the floors
mistake
across this because a carve-out and you
ever let you go and there we will call
they'll shake and watch them move and if
you step in two years I just [ __ ]
help our valves trust ya you would sit
there and feet would just stick in huh
you know how night it was a Capone place
but the daytime it was like you know see
four hearts and like officer the
gentleman for five bucks I like an old
movie theater man there's something cool
about like about seeing like Casablanca
or something like real old and a movie
theater you see a black and white film
on a big screen you're like [ __ ] this is
how you got to see it something about
watching at home you just don't you you
connect so much harder in a theater man
I really enjoy going to see all these
films of my daughter I want to see that
one yesterday and I basically sat down
caught one upcoming trailer and I fell
asleep I'd sat by myself my wife and
there was only one movie the one with
Harrison Ford and the dog of the wild
one whatever the [ __ ] that I don't know
do you know they play like 30 minutes of
trailers at AMC now oh yeah it's the
greediest [ __ ] I've ever seen there's
commercials and then there's 30 minutes
of trailers and you're like dude I
didn't expect to be this is an hour and
a half movie I'm gonna be here close to
you know two and a half hours and how
it's crazy it's really crazy how the
whole theatre experiences change yeah
you know compared when I was a kid yeah
you had your you didn't have the change
you had your big movie theater hmm but
then you also had the community movie
theater where the movie wasn't hot
anymore
this is the fourth week if you wanna pay
the four bucks to see you already paid
it now it's down to like two bucks
smaller place you know I like those I
grew up in those I think the neatest
movie theater I went to was San
Francisco in 85 I want to see masks and
this movie theater had couches and
sticky floors
no not skittishness yeah the place is
spotless yeah and the
kitchen was spotless and they made
chocolate chip cookies from scratch
yeah right out of the oven oh oh no no
this was just a tremendous and they made
popcorn and you would see the lady
putting a stick of butter in the heater
yeah and melting real butter I mean this
was legit you know what I like in a
movie theater a movie theater that sells
like cashews because you know you're
gonna get like a documentary or a good
foreign film yeah you see you see nuts
for sale you look alright these people
take their [ __ ] seriously I like it
I like I still I don't want the movie
experience to grow like I went to a
movie theater in Toronto one time and
they had a waitstaff
yeah and you and they were serving
alcohol and that's cool you sit there
and go that's cool but that's movement
it is I don't like them and it's not
forward progress
it's just movement it doesn't add to the
movie experience I don't I don't need to
get drunk to watch a movie you know you
you look at the [ __ ] you go online
and the movie says it starts at 140
you know you do 20,000 things you wash
your [ __ ] I take that [ __ ] everything
that could go wrong could go wrong the
cat pukes on the way out you get that
140 and then you basically do sit there
for a half a [ __ ] hour yeah watch of
these reveal you know over and over
these things in the movie you don't even
know what the [ __ ] is going on like it's
six trailers or supination I hate it you
can watch III think like three or four
trailers man three trailer yeah
to excite me yeah that's it so don't
like different genre trailers like if
you're in a comedy and they just show
you like horror trailers you're like
that's not I'm not a horror guy man it's
just not my genre but I don't I also
don't like I mean as you said taking the
[ __ ] in a [ __ ] in a movie theater I'm
very lactose intolerant I beat it I feel
like I beat the the disorder I don't
really have it as much anymore but I had
it bad I would just so I would I was so
mad I had as a kid that I would eat like
cheeseburger mozzarella sticks milkshake
I'm like everything to like and every
once in a while I would be in like
horrible pain I was in one of those
Times Square movie theaters just
horrible stomachache just liquid coming
out of me the worst and I just hear dad
and
outside the stall laughing at me and I
hear the dad go that boys got this [ __ ]
it made me everybody like one of those
moments where you're in so much pain
you're like however that's pretty good a
pretty good lie go to college I did I
went to I went to Tulane for a year and
a half of New Orleans and then um it was
right when Katrina hit so I ended up
leaving but uh I end up finishing New
York City at NYU
and what do you think would you major it
I majored in a made-up major that was
like a writing major but I kind of made
it so I was already doing stand-up so I
kind of made it I was doing like barking
at nights and handing out flyers and
nights and doing stage and at night so I
kind of manipulated it to be about
comedy but well you were them were you
yeah but it ended up I had to do make it
academic so it was ancient Greek comedy
so it was like 400 BC but I'll tell you
man those old plays dick joke fart joke
[ __ ] sex joke like every every like
it's this comedy has not changed which
is kind of a it's kind of cool there's
that famous Greek play Lysistrata where
you just can't that you're going to the
men are at war and the women won't [ __ ]
the man until the war is over that's how
they stand and you're like that's from
400 BC that's that's kind of cool I
think I don't know so I'd have to make
it academic to please them but I just
well I knew I loved comedy I love doing
stand-up so much so I may as well while
I'm here do this stuff you know what
hold me the first time we on stage 19
you said I was 18 the first time but I
was it was like probably like two months
before it turn 19 I was at the con I did
the class at the comic strip in New York
City DF sweedler taught a class there
and my one of my best friends still Joe
Mack he just happened to be in the class
so I met usually it's like those people
were just like bored but like we both
really love stand-up and I could I could
sense he loved it and he it was good for
me because DF was like I was so dirty in
the class every joke was I was a kid so
every joke was like drinking sex and he
was he said just try to write a few
clean jokes too cuz it's harder to go
from from dirty to clean than clean the
dirty so just have that tool he said
yeah so I liked and I said I love Dave
Attell and I gave him all these comics I
liked he said well tell convite clean at
Ellis done late night sets
so he was he's actually a lot of those
early teachers are like you know we'll
get you on Letterman in six weeks
trust me but he didn't make any promises
he was like I'll just make you a little
more organized
will you is this 2005 Wow
yeah I took the classic New York Comedy
Club no [ __ ]
1993 to taught it I forget the guys name
but I just been bumped into him maybe
three years ago in Burbank Wow didn't
even know was him we were talking like
the you member teaching in classical's
absolutely and his main thing was
stand-up how your world collides with
the rest of the world yeah and I'm a
ma'am asked me one day like who next
week bring in who your favorite comic is
some [ __ ] brought in Gallagher tons
of jerk los brought in Cosby as usual
and a lot of late Bill Hicks on I mean
it's like I'm gonna pay attention to you
yeah you're really into this [ __ ] you
know I forgot we but that was if I got
anything I have forget what it was a
hundred bucks for eight weeks yeah I
took what I'm bold which got me on stage
in Boulder Boulder
that's why I got on stage the first time
was Boulder yeah was Denver Denver
Comedy Works oh [ __ ] okay 91 Wow
I went to New York to develop in 93 it
was too heavy for me mad it was too
heavy of a [ __ ] jungle and I couldn't
I didn't see myself going anywhere and
after he planted that it was too clicky
it is the open mics in New York when I
started working really quickie at that
time yeah
huggable can't complain people Adam but
it's hard to get noticed in anyway I was
just really open like some one guy who
say what I say do my bars show I was
trying to get real shows and and those
mics men especially because my jokes
were show like the punchline was so
obvious I was doing a lot of one-liners
that if they would bomb I would bomb I
would feel those bombs hard and then and
I don't even mind bombing but the amount
of mentally ill people you'd have to
encounter with these mics man I'd be
like bother the basement level
is I used to go to a place on 15th and
8th Avenue used to be Goodfellas pizza
yeah right down to Kelowna from
Manhattan Honda man that bomber was like
23rd Street yeah this bar you made like
a right on 15th Street you walk like 30
yards there's an open mic I don't know
what night it was
there open mic started then it was just
a dive and I remember being in there
with a pimp yeah and there with three
holes and working the hose yo yo yo play
it to me you won't get your dick suck
and you're on stage you're on [ __ ]
stage you know and you're like no and
then afterwards like you know he's not
even talking to you
I still specifically remember just
feeling like yeah am I gonna say
suicidal in New York I wasn't suicidal I
just felt like it wasn't going anywhere
I had started in Denver I'm the
difference between Denver and New York
at that time was a them to bring five
people and a lot of comics had their own
rooms
so comics went into bars and asked for a
three to one dollar budget and everybody
got 50 bucks and you know four people
got to go onstage yeah I didn't see that
till I went to New York and saw how hard
I was working to get onstage you know
I've never gone on an open mic he used
to start at 11:00 the old triple and 11
o'clock went till 4:00 the only times I
was dead a quarter of [ __ ] 11:00 and
I was already number 67 yeah like you
serious like we it's 10:30 the lineup
opens up at 10:30 and I'm already 67
it's brutal I mean dude yeah so Joe
Mackey and I used to do what it was
called late night the comic strip so
does the regular show starts at 8:00 and
then at like 10:30 or so maybe 10:45
they start late night and then so that's
like already you know it's already 2
hours 45 minutes of crowd sitting
through the show so they let you go on
do five minutes instead of 15 and Mackey
and I would get the
like 7:40 to be the first to sign up and
then didn't matter if we were the first
they had this other side a late night
that got to just cut us so these were
like guys that didn't work the club but
have been around for like 20 years so
the guys who just didn't work on their
acts they were just guys some of them
would just go up and do street jokes and
they just get that they'd show up at
like 10:30 and it would be there three
hours they just get to cut us so then
we'd go on sometimes like 11:45 there's
like three people left four people but
you know to us it was like well we're
hanging and we're bouncing bits and
we're like talking comedy so that was
good for us and then even just saying
the jokes the three people I felt like
it was something you know some nights
the crowd was good but it made us I
remember Mike DeStefano it was a really
funny guy who just he passed away yeah a
very funny guy and very like kind of a
there was a gonna honesty to him onstage
he was like he was a really kind guy
who's really funny there was yeah he
just was a member he saw it Macky and I
won nine he said I like you too cuz you
you stay in the corner you shut the [ __ ]
up and he just bounced jokes he's like
and that's what young comics should do
he said you don't bother anybody you
don't bother the pros and we're like
alright guess I guess what us being in
the corners good you know it's just got
to keep showing up and he kinda that was
like I think his way of encouraging us
and now the other comics would say they
give us like a hint that we were doing
the right thing a little bit and I I
thought the Commish sure was pretty good
for developing jokes it's crazy that you
did that at the comic strip and when I
moved here in 97 Josh wolf and I talked
to Aaron Bontempo into letting us do a
show at eleven at The Improv she says I
don't know people gonna come but you
know I don't know how many times the
host would say guys we have another show
if you want to stick around and again
six people would hang yeah you know and
it was Josh me and then [ __ ] the word
got out you know and then I was gonna
hate people and ten then twelve we're
doing okay with and then Damon Way and
started bumping us he would come in at
10:30
and just stamp dental [ __ ] one damn
Wednesday Myrtle it breaks you [ __ ]
heart it does young comic you know and I
had another complaint about I was
getting spots at the store but it was
nice that you're at least in the improv
farm League yeah I know now you could do
it now they have like the room next to
it the lab and you know at this time it
was just the improv that's it how
Hollywood wants to show ended the show
wasn't like the Comedy Store run still
to the improv with him like at 11:00
then yeah but even like that there was a
guy Rick do come in who was in Groundhog
Day really funny guy he told me when he
got into comedy in LA that The Improv
was told them if you want a high or if
you want to pay somebody to go back
there and put the lights on cuz we have
to cut our guy at 10:30 damn they
suddenly by the hour will let you do
whatever you want and he said [ __ ] it it
was worth for me to pay somebody by the
hour I would get a couple comic strip
and we made flyers and it goes we at
least we performed to real people
instead of an open mic you know that
that meant everything to me is that the
mics just as you said they're so clicky
I go I'd be working on bits and there'll
be comics going up there doing inside
jokes with other comics in the crowd and
I said man I'm trying to build an act
I'm trying to like figure out Joe it's
very tough and you figure out your path
it's like water we water always finds a
path ok the more we get onstage we find
the path yeah like we you find the path
out of that lunacy there's that bottom
ground lunacy where some of them are
homeless
some of them is mental health you don't
want key in Phoenix you know you know
son and then you graduate yeah bigger
and better things but that as time goes
on and also when you decide you're not
going back there yeah and it also
depends on when the comic says I'm not
doing this [ __ ] oh yeah it feels good to
know if they can sense the desperation
and they know who's gonna come back and
they and they just knew what they could
I mean
the comic strip was our first club so
they kind of never gave us respect as
stand-ups because they just always saw
us as just nothing I was a comic strip
today I think Jerry Seinfeld and Adam
Sandler doing specials in there kind of
gave it a second win but it's they make
a lot of mistakes you know they it's a
great room the room is beautiful it's
just like there's something about it as
a comedy room that's like kind of
perfect but I mean they really uh they
could be booking
they could be booking a lot of really
good comics that they don't book and I
think it's kind of always been that way
and I think that's always been the the
thing on the comic strip the comics they
don't book them all the comics don't
cause I think both I think I think I'm
sure the first part feeds the second
part you know I think they just know
that they don't like I've given them
names that people I said you should book
this person they're really good and
they're and they're gonna kill your room
and they're always like we'll take it
they'll give him like one spot and then
never again what about Stan of New York
what's that like now it's falling off a
little bit too it's yeah there's bad
ownership they just kind of once they
once they start panicking they just do
too many produced shows and you kind of
lose a good rotation of comics that
there should be there so I'd say in the
city the best clubs the Comedy Cellar
Gotham the stand is good New York Comedy
Club is two locations that are the new
ownership really good so those are those
are two good rooms
those are your favorites yeah definitely
and the comic strip Dangerfield's all
those Dangerfield's it's pretty rough
they actually shot the scene for the
Joker right angel and I think the thing
was it's a rundown club I heard a story
about Dangerfield's at one time Chris
Rock walked in there and they said whoa
whoa whoa twenty bucks
and he said I'm Chris Rock and and they
could take a guy just looked at the
bartender and he goes all right let him
in like not like sorry you're Chris Rock
we might want you to go onstage like all
right fine which is like that's just
tells you everything you know well I
went back this last time I did spots of
Dangerfield's I'm just like eight people
a night I enjoyed it yeah it reminded me
a lot of a comedy story at The Comedy
Store feel yeah I have to go to New York
on a few weeks
I have a few nights I don't know what
I'm gonna do with my nights I know that
I have like two nights I have nothing I
can probably book her a night but I'm
shooting so I don't really worry
I heard congratulations yeah I'm getting
too involved in this yeah I hate when
you think you're not gonna do something
I got a call that would be live and go
I'm shooting you know but I just keep it
light and go back and see what the
schedule takes me in one for any of
those clubs would be very happy to have
you yeah no I like all those clubs I
like I enjoy all those [ __ ]
Club so yeah I never go down the Konami
seller I think it's too it's too
political for me oh really
type of guy that I am yeah my way I
can't sit at the table you could [ __ ]
like that you absolutely cannot want to
go through that yeah but everyone will
be able to say hello my mom in New York
I'm the last to the real New York
because I mean there was a [ __ ] table
so before anything happens why even go
there
I'm not some guy that moved here from
[ __ ] Indianapolis I'm the last or the
real [ __ ] from the Westside
yeah like my summer camp was 148 Street
between Bert Broadway beside Drive down
there that's why I saw my first body and
it's nothing but you know it's not jelly
it's not gonna get to it this is in your
head
oh no yeah no one's like no one's like
the [ __ ] is this guy want to go hey man
what it's not it's not like that it's a
head back I feel I get what you mean I
feel the same way the Comedy Store
yeah I'm not you walk go what the [ __ ]
you doing here yeah I did my show my
hour in the Comedy Store on Friday and
of course the guys tossing me the door
like oh my god damn it all right here
yeah kind of weird that because it's New
York
it's how I conduct myself on the streets
of Los Angeles will be completely
different than how I conduct myself on
the streets in New York it's really
weird you know I'm saying because
they're all how you have to conduct
yourself in New York if not you're gonna
[ __ ] get caught if you have to beat
someone up take it out of my friend Joe
Mackay
you know hold all you can take
I'm [ __ ] around I just know it yeah
comics say weird [ __ ] sometime well no
one's gonna say anything needed up
that's all in your head you're assuming
the worst
sometimes I said listen Dawg I've heard
[ __ ] even here yeah I hear [ __ ] here so
that's why I go to the commies so I keep
them at arm's distance also I love it's
my home yeah it's like a gun on it seven
nights a week sure because the younger
comics like what the [ __ ] bro you're an
old man Almond [ __ ] go make a sweater
I'm saying you didn't take a spot say
we're gonna be on Conan next week with
the [ __ ] yeah the only Conan you are was
BC you know so [ __ ] like that's on my
mind yeah you're probably right but I
just uh I just like to perform with no
drop I'm the same way man yeah I like
writing jokes and telling jokes I don't
want to deal with it the hangs the hang
stresses me out here and also dude that
the fact that the shows are so spaced
out I'm like [ __ ] that was I did two
spots like five and a half hours here
you know it's a lot last week no it's
like it takes forever cuz like some of
some of the shows this store usually but
some shows don't give you a spot time so
you're just hanging out and you're like
that's cool that you at least get love
at the store yeah well I'm not past this
store but I'll get like Sam Tripoli's
been awesome they'll throw me up and you
know so you're doing Tuesday with triple
yeah I did the last one
although hey yeah yeah I did a lay I did
he sent me on a few times he's he's
great
and I did one last night in the main
room Brian monarch show hot show I mean
yeah it's it's such a great it's a great
room man this store is awesome but I
don't feel comfortable there it's not
you know I'm a New York I'm a seller guy
so now when did you when you first got
to come here at my you were your parents
and my parents are pretty supportive at
the time I think my my parents are
pretty concerned it was an excuse for me
to just get shit-faced all the time
which they probably weren't far off you
know when you're young you know I got
free alcohol this is cool but you know
my mom is an artist she's very creative
my dad is a is a lawyer so I think he's
more practical my mom was a little bit
more like as long as you're not getting
[ __ ] up we support this and I was
getting [ __ ] up so they weren't
supporting that and then and then and
then they started you know what the the
night they kind of I think got it is I
opened for Jim Jeffries in the Best Buy
Theater in in Times Square and it must
have been like two thousand people a
show or so and and it went well and they
were like wow that this guy Jim Jeffries
is so good and he has Sam two open so I
think they were kind of like maybe this
isn't [ __ ] you know maybe this is
because they'd see me in clubs and stuff
but they hadn't seen that so I was it
take you to get started to go from
hoping Mike to the [ __ ] you know we
were talking about competitions and I
hated the comedy competition so much
dude they some of them were but that's
what made me work that's what gave me
that's what was got me paid on stages is
my jokes were very short they were even
short now they even shorter them so I
would I would do comedy competitions and
it would they did one called March
Madness which is like bracket style it
starts like one minute versus one minute
then it's like three minutes versus
three minutes and five so you going
one-on-one with a comic as they're
sitting there I I would open by going
this is like eight mile for Jews that
was my opener and then I would have to
like just go into material you know it
was like [ __ ] this is intense and you
just sit there while the other person's
killing it's [ __ ] it I hated it it
was my least favorite thing but I've
also was like this is also getting me
work so I what really put me over the
top was this festival called The
Laughing Skull it lat and Lana when my
2010 or 11 I did um I did it and I won
the festival in the prize was you got
some money but the prize I was excited
about was guaranteed there was like six
months to a year of road work so that
got me just on the road and now with all
I wanted it's like I want to be a road
comic so it's crazy how the contest I
did Seattle yeah it was [ __ ] great in
95 that's a long one it's not like three
weeks that's brutal
and you starve you know but it's that
camaraderie yeah that thing that lets
you know that it just really opened up
my
I said that I'm really thankful for that
one San Francisco I quit on Saturday I
did the San Francisco one when I moved
up here yeah somebody suggested I should
do San Francisco and at that time in 97
it was a scam yeah just by that time it
was just a scam comics were [ __ ]
judging yeah it's like me going up Sam
what up nothing great time at your
mother's party the other night really
how do we gotta [ __ ] win that
happened to me yeah happy gonna win if I
know Sam personally say that [ __ ] up
that was it destroyed my insides like I
worked hard at the store I got the
limits the set limits you know it's six
minutes you got to wrap it up and Sam
you gotta get off stage you go over 70
deduct the point I don't think I ever
want to judge a comedy competition it's
awful and you know when I first passed
the comic strip they made me do five
minutes and I remember so they just
didn't want to pass me they would like
and I give them some respect for this
they really were still in a haze in
which I think you know what is nothing a
little a little uh a little hazy never
makes you a worse stand-up but it did
hurt at the time because I thought hey
what are you just like they would [ __ ]
with me a little bit nothing like cruel
just like they would could they kind of
[ __ ] with me we're like an example as
they said you know I was doing really
well he saw me do really well on
late-night warrants and he goes alright
maybe you're ready for an audition and I
said I'm ready to work the lineup I felt
that Joe Mac you know we're ready to
work the lineup for a while and he said
alright we'll put you on they put me on
at the end of the late and so they do a
late night audition but it's at the end
of late night so it's like the first
time I audition it starts with 80 people
in the crowd maybe you know and some guy
before me had a [ __ ] meltdown on
stage he walked everyone for 12 people
and I'm waiting all night I'm waiting
three hours i watch this guy just have a
[ __ ] meltdown I was and I was just
like begging him like please don't walk
that last 12 I need this you know so I
went up in it and it went well for those
12 people I was very calm I kind of rift
on what just happened obviously and I
said you know I need this so thanks for
staying and did the act so I got another
shot and then he put me on it was a full
crowd this time and three comics with
the judges and I [ __ ] I
it went really well Sherrod small was
hosting it and Chihuahuas like this dude
deserves to work here he said that
before and he said they're making him go
through X he's having an audition like
there's like a second time auditioning
for the main lineup after he's already
been doing the the late-night for a few
years so I think he should be here and
second time in like a month and then I
went on went real well
Keith Robinson's one of the judges I
love Keith and he was real nice Greer
Barnes who I love was real nice and then
another comic I won't even say his name
before I do it but he he said I think
you're kind of hacky and I don't respect
this guy's act so to me I and I didn't
been either and I said well I said well
you know what are you gonna do that's
that's your opinion you know and then
the guy who booked the club said yeah
I've seen that five minutes before and I
said well it's an audition man so marina
Franklin who was already cool to me then
to is it was a great comic she came in
the room and she was if she was a little
drunk and she said [ __ ] you to the bus
in front of the whole crowd that look
lads booing him and they were recording
this it's I'm sure there's footage of it
somewhere which is [ __ ] humiliating
and she just said you know [ __ ] you like
it's an audition he should be allowed to
do whatever five minutes he wants you
know so then he said alright how about
you come back and do it again next week
this is the third time now so I said
alright [ __ ] you I said new five and he
said alright so the whole thing goes
down again it couldn't have gone better
again and you know thank God you know
this to finally he's like alright fine
you can work here and then but it's not
like I got spots I was past but it's not
like you're working so me I got it I got
a different outtake of this whole thing
I love my background was being a
criminal and you know I had fun growing
up with the whole thing people who live
in glass houses shouldn't throw stones
yeah I'll deal with amazing you won't
call me a spec I don't not even like
that but no I know one thing that really
always agitated me till this day well I
about it but there's certain people I
won't work for because I know this
shitty to young college yeah and I don't
understand you know you and me were cool
but when the comic is young I don't like
when people treat young Thomas shitty
because I got treated so shitty yeah my
first three isn't a business except for
my house and C job outside of that like
I was always that guy that was told to
be then 830 but when I got there I found
that I had to follow the headliner and I
had like I was gonna blow his [ __ ] on
fire you know I was always that guy that
sat there for three hours I'm not
holding a penny party I'm holding it but
he bought it no definitely not out like
yeah I know what it felt like going to
sign up at 10:30 reading Judi Carter's
book I've heard you to carry the [ __ ]
exercises to man staying up till 4:00
you know yeah really watching stand-up
studying it on in those days I didn't
have the internet guys I had to go to
Blockbuster do you knew hex and that
zone egg but the fact that you say I
think hex is kind of it I know some
people think he's over it I think it's
still kind of underrated because he put
out 5 [ __ ] great hours and he died a
33 it's insane it's insane it's insane
how good he worn his [ __ ] holds up hard
that [ __ ] is bad and there was some
stuff that was very out there yeah for
some people it's even out there for me
but the more I did comedy the more I
understood yeah what he was doing why he
was doing it he was like an all comic
with Club chops you know he the only
time I didn't love him was when he got
like a little self-righteous but like
when he was just telling hard jokes I
might [ __ ] this guy's incredible is
Rodney special is still one of my
favorite unreal pieces of work in comedy
of all time it's like a perfect
late-night says it's it's and yeah I had
a followed dice that line up David
Robert Schimmel yeah in the room one for
Dahmer era every comic was so funny you
print
when I got into comedy I rented that so
much at the people with video places
don't even worry about no more
just-just-just you're the only one who
rents this there was - there was that
one with him and there was the other one
with Roseanne and Kennison Kennison I
remember Chimel opener it's like one of
the funniest openers I've ever heard of
my life on that set I still remember
where he goes I read that a guy got
arrested for animal necrophilia what do
you say to the judge I'm sorry Your
Honor I thought the cat was alive wall
is [ __ ] it that's a great joke he had
that bitty head on there was tremendous
Chimel was cellphone he had something on
there about his mother using a vibrator
yes and for years he thought it was his
parents making margaritas in the bedroom
or some [ __ ] all those things with my
blueprints Oh calm it's so weird that
till this day there's people I talk to I
go out of my way to talk to because
those first three or four years of
County there was gentlemen to me yeah
but there's still people who I see on
Facebook that would dicks to me that now
I won't like throw a [ __ ] dart at
them because they [ __ ] with you dream
but listen if you sell Coakley and take
your round you deserve everything that
you got you're dealing in poisons what
do you thinks gonna happen but in this
thing we're dealing dreams yeah
we're dealing in something that not you
know there's a big difference again I'm
not taking away from that nobody there's
a big difference to me being electrician
and me being a comic there's still but
there's still similarities there you
still have the apprenticeship whatever
and I guarantee when you're an
apprentice electrician they break your
balls they make you go up to a roof to
pick up that wire and they all laughing
it's the same thing it's the same thing
I get it but there was some people to me
in comedy that was just over the top
yeah I want to make you feel like [ __ ]
well dude think it's think about how
many comics there are like [ __ ] if this
were easy think about how many more
comics there would be you know like I
guess they have to they have to relax
somehow
yeah but you know yeah those nights I'll
always remember like there were a lot of
nights like that obviously went for any
comic when you start out so yeah I
remember those and yeah it was it was a
the the strip kind of formed me of the
type of comic I am a lot because you
know he had had to kill quickly and you
had to you remember wait around so and
we might you live down the strip now and
you know not not much oh you don't go
down no I'm more of a cellar guy now cuz
I just nights a week
FC ST yeah I'll do all that she give you
if I'm in town usually every night she's
been she's been I mean it's been it's
been a while there you know it's I've
been there for a while now so she's been
always really good I got you to gold
place yeah because also would hit the
stand I don't work there at a time but I
like the club I I'm usually at the
cellar a New York Comedy Club of the two
one thing or the most I think but I love
I think the stands a great Clara would
come New York Comedy Club I'd the Blues
great yeah there's there's one on yet
fourth and the one on 24th the one on
fourth it's great that was you should do
you should pop in you should pop in all
them when you're in dad was good it's
good that was downstairs yeah that
little stoop down stairs like a little
bar up front yeah that was diamonds
amazing that was dynamite and I heard
she's got another place yeah she's right
for a me books it and Amelia runs it and
it's it's great man yeah she's got a
room where you up to 50 minutes 150
right re does it maybe I don't know
12:24 Street how big is 24th Street 150
maybe they're not both not huge they're
just you know they're just good rooms
you have a look you know who I met in
New York Comedy Club in 93 yeah Mike
whatever DeStefano know the kid who does
the podcast already laying Oh Mike
Bocchetti
Mike Gousha such a nice guy used to have
a joke I'm from Staten Island I work on
a bakery I'm in charge of the thoughts
that me and my friends [ __ ] lost it
well he said that right if we [ __ ]
lost it like that that's how far back I
got Mike Bocchetti
and that club believer that they were
good to me
Lucius said some horrible things to me
from the comic show yeah he died [ __ ]
Brian help the guy at 73rd Street how
many we just talked about it right on
the west side there Oh West and of New
York
stand up New York that guy was a prick
yeah the guy who used on it was going
around town telling people had a
multi-million dollar developmental deal
and with his wife and they were gonna
give comics deals it was just a [ __ ]
nightmare yeah man I remember one night
I got into it with him because I went
down there was Joe Rogan and I don't
know where this guy came up to Joey
knows he wanna go on next or what
tonight chuckles yeah and he looked
right at me and he knows you don't even
ask I didn't even know him Wow did I ask
you stupid [ __ ] damn I'm looking
at Joe and Joe look at that reinjure
going Joey we can tell [ __ ] this [ __ ]
and it was still just Sussman walking me
outside like that's how weird it was you
know I won't [ __ ] with a lot of these
people because I'll just strangle a lot
of the club's you walk in you work on
the way up or the ones you kind of never
go back to and it's not because you
don't like have loyalty it's like a lot
of those clubs just don't do it well
they don't treat you well and they don't
treat anyone well so you're kind of like
I mean I used to work this Club Broadway
comedy club all the time and I'd worked
the door there and stuff and like me
working the door with this frame who the
[ __ ] am I gonna throw out come on you
know so it's like [ __ ] would go down and
I'm a comic would be like this is the
[ __ ] security and I'd be like yeah
sorry this is what they this is who they
have May so I'd have to deal with people
and it's like I'm not dealing with any
remember I got someone spat on me on
stage there once because you know I'd
worked the doors let me go on stage and
yeah I just I I became close with the
with the waitstaff because they were
just all really cool and nice and and I
think they felt like all right he's one
of us because he's working the door and
stuff so I remember being on stage once
he was going at it with a guy and he he
just goes I kind of put him down but he
gets
and I just I hear his girlfriend go not
it not again
and I'm like what the what not again and
I just hear him go home [ __ ] spits right
right in my chest it was like they kind
of blocked him from getting any closer
to me but I was like yeah how do i how
do I turn this set around I think this
one's done you know so he kind of waits
out he's like I'm gonna wait outside for
you I'm like [ __ ] all right it's been
quite a journey yes it's fine but you
know what those show is now are pretty
funny to look back on you know cuz you
feels like there's no you don't you know
there's never a moment you're more
humiliated than bombing with someone
else's spit on your chest it's just like
[ __ ] it that's like you're that's got to
be one of the rock bottom moments you
know but it's also kind of it's also
kind of great in a weird way because I
remember that night this comic Chris
Murphy was like I'm gonna walk you out
because I want to make sure that if he
jumps you I'm there with you and I was
like that's a [ __ ] good guy you know
so you kind of make these weird bonds in
those moments too right you just remind
me of a lot of [ __ ] I also do a lot of
great things happen but the bad stuffs
more interesting to reminisce on you
know I I mean goddamn I'm with the
sellers been amazing to me Gary Gulman
recommended me at the club in 2011 and
it was like changed my life you know
Gary Gulman such a [ __ ] great dude
and I featured from once on the road and
I got offstage and he goes you're gonna
be the first guy wreck at the Comedy
Cellar I've never actually got you're
gonna be the first I didn't even know it
meant so much to me so so people have
been so kind in those moments to so you
know the bad stuffs interesting but the
good stuff is good stuff is tremendous
the good stuff and and the good stuff is
really so I'm grave and the sellers been
[ __ ] amazing to me so you know when
you have a job if you go to work for me
at my freight company yeah every
eighteen months by Union rules I have to
give you a 1.8 percent raise and you
feel kind of good about it I really pay
much you gotta raise big [ __ ] deal
you know with comedy it's not a raise
it's like a moral victory yes
you get moral victories it's not money
it's not even about money if you're
looking for money you're walking down
the wrong
it's moral victories you know the most
I'll [ __ ] with a comic the Sam commits
I'm in minutes you got man I can do 14
and that's if I talk about the next 12
and then I won't put the light on yeah
that's the best thing I could do for a
cop yeah it's a torture chamber
but finally had an hour you gonna go uh
I I thought it was 12 minutes but you
gonna learn the lesson of your life yeah
I think me telling you Sam give me a
ride to this gig I'm gonna give you 25
bucks and you're an open mic and there's
2,000 people there and also they go Sam
go do eight minutes in you're like I
thought I was just driving that's my
dream break for the people yeah I love
doing that to people whatever bad
positions as a comic that if they have
to survive yeah that's how you become a
comic you don't become a comic by you
know you become with comics by getting
put into bad positions come in how much
time you got like 21 and that's if I
talk about New York City
isn't it funny when people give you an
exact like I knew a guy Gary Peters oh I
would see I would tell you the truth you
tell he said 18 I always told you true
here I didn't want no problems yeah and
I would I was raised by if you going for
a job and the guy says to you do you
know what computer technology is no I
don't but I'm willing to learn yeah that
means more and the guy that comes in and
says yeah I know everything about
computers well guess what now I have to
retrain you and that might be hard
because you already established bad
habits yeah so you follow uh say
anything with me I'd rather get you and
you form them when they're young you
know yeah I'm them boom boom boom that's
the torture I inflict on the cops that
would be the torture like we'd wait yeah
and just walk out of the room yeah and
go back in at 29 yeah he doesn't know
what the [ __ ] hit him but he might pull
[ __ ] out of his ass yeah that he's gonna
leave that
not sleep that night because that's what
usually happens on those and that makes
you write when you're like [ __ ] that I
need to have more time yeah fear will
make fear is a good motivator man I
really here are these jokes
listen I want you to be out of your
jokes I love everything that you've ever
written in a notebook and you started to
use Cosby's first now that's when I come
and give you the light all right
at least I believe you he's not using
the jokes and yeah use them so copy and
I'll give you two lights I don't know
buddies I put you in a bad position but
it's a bad you know it's it's it's
that's how you get good at comedy yeah
man and that but then so much good stuff
happens I mean you think about this
stuff and everyone has us every comic
has those stories and that's what school
is like I remember like seeing guys I
used to like hand out the Flyers in the
street with and you're like oh that's
like a dude I care about you know like
it's almost like we had some weird like
it was really cold with New York City
I was drinking out of a flask to stay
warm you know and now we're splitting
the flask and handing out flyers and
[ __ ] I mean it definitely is it
definitely is pretty cool and you ever
do that where you hand out the Flyers to
people at the show and then they come in
the show you like it's a hot show
tonight we got all this person this
person and then they walk in and they're
like two or four people in there and
then I'm the next comic onstage and like
you [ __ ] you lied to me
see well I got to New York and then he
threw the weren't Barker's yeah we would
have to sell tickets oh yeah no no they
would give you a book a ticket oh yeah
and you had a lead they were given to
you for three dollars and you sold them
for ten and you gotta give the club to
three Wow I was into it I did it one
summer I was really angry yeah I made
money doing it yeah and then one day one
weekend I sold like a the Hollywood my
go [ __ ] Lucian this money is mine and I
wear back they're like where's the 30
bucks yo so I mailed it to you isn't it
amazing that you carry that [ __ ] again
solution still cuz I feel the same way
like you never really get over cuz it's
still kind of like a like the injustice
I'm a delusion but there is I say Lucien
because he was there yeah there's people
I'm not mad at because
I wasn't even ready to be in that
presence yeah
do you know I'm saying sure I can't be
mad at them
there were people who said things that
shouldn't have said it
yeah but one of the biggest listen
because we can get better - that's what
they forget I'm gonna get better we're
gonna come back the yeah I'm gonna come
back and eat you [ __ ] about Vegas you
know Oh like there was a lady in Seattle
she didn't like me I got into a beef one
day
giggles no her name was Laura crock God
rest his soul all these people are
mysteriously dead Joe she's dead she
dies my father dead I don't know I
she was Josh wolf manager okay for a
while she managed in Seattle and she
booked rooms and it was well known that
I got into a beef with somebody and she
took that person side and yeah pretty
much banned from booking me Wow
but I said [ __ ] it I'm a good comic I
got a good 25 minutes I'm not like
anybody else in Seattle
there's no New Yorkers in Seattle so I
would call her every Monday to annoy her
and go Wednesday nights amarelle his
headlining chichis and she had like
eight rooms during the week it's not the
worst when they have [ __ ] actual a
little bit of power really like good
rules so I would call her up and
stillness and I wouldn't tell her that
was smoking coke would samurai late in
the morning I would just say Sam said I
could do 10 minutes and follow that you
know fine and then I would go down then
2 to 10 minutes and the club the guy who
owned the bar will come up to Mingo
why don't you ever work here and I would
say Laura doesn't like me personally
yeah hey when I'm at the Comedy Store
and I'm rocking and rolling I think of
Laura Crocker
because her hatred towards me made me
work harder to prove her wrong yeah
even if she's dead today she doesn't
matter you know god rest her soul whole
thing I still proved her wrong she
didn't like me over something had
nothing to do with her yeah nothing to
do with us she just said I don't like
Joey Diaz and this is the way it's gonna
be and I had to live with it and I had
to accept it but there were just people
would just [ __ ] cruel [ __ ] I still
want to like the houses on fire but who
gives a [ __ ] at this point
they haven't moved forward at all in
their life they were so busy criticizing
young comics and criticizing their tapes
and making them feel bad that today then
move forward yeah some of them are dicks
but their dicks in like a funny way in a
way so I look back and I'm kind of like
I was kind of funny you know like I mean
there was this Club I play forever in
Tampa and I you know I started featuring
there and it's it's a really good Club
is called side splitters yeah great club
and I remember Bobby jewel
oh my god when I he booked me as a
feature out of the gate as a young comic
so they took forever of course to
headline me but I remember he would just
get [ __ ] loaded like hairpiece pinky
ring pissed drunk picking me up in his
Mercedes like just a character you know
and he still had the club no he's out
he's out now but uh man he would get in
my face and be like you [ __ ] [ __ ] I
pee sitting in the dirt and I'm like you
can outdrink me at 58 yeah
congratulations you can [ __ ] leave me
in the dirt he would [ __ ] get loaded
he'd walk in the bar just [ __ ] ripped
his own bar like they would tell me like
you were losing like 40 grand a year
liquor sales from Bobby you just get
[ __ ] ripped and he would walk in and
just start he would make a [ __ ] it he'd
make a fucked-up joke and then someone
would look at him he bit like the [ __ ]
are you looking at in his own [ __ ]
Club to me I was like I mean I guess I'm
not the only one goodness it was kind of
funny but he would he would he'd be kind
of a dick but also it's like I don't
know man like when you see those dudes
you're like well there's none of you
left so let me just enjoy it you know
what I mean like how many clubs am I
gonna go to no there's none of those
guys
so it Scott you do kind of appreciate it
he would just get in my [ __ ] face
every time like you [ __ ] [ __ ] I hear
I hear little whispers here and there of
people you know this certain clubs I
don't like how they treat their feature
acts yeah you know I don't wanna listen
you gotta be good to the people all the
way up because you're gonna see the same
people on the way totally I'm not here
that start wars with clubs no no no but
I hear about a lot of clubs that don't
listen you hire a feature put him on a
motel 6 for three nights right you know
you don't pay the feature a hundred a
set which is [ __ ] ridiculous yes well
that's 1958 money so saying it you know
I see a 15 minutes that locally or
something yeah once you make somebody
get up leave their house get on a plane
or a train or a [ __ ] [ __ ]
internship you should pay them election
the feature emcee money has not changed
and [ __ ] twine and then some
headliners don't let the feature sell
[ __ ] merch I might do the guys
getting 500 for the weekend let it all
work so the feature my headliner who I'm
working with it's elbert yeah totally I
don't want it so much I don't ever want
to sell merch I don't want to look at
people I don't want to look at shirt
sizes I don't want to get cornered by a
drunk that's the me I used to sell shirt
so that was a feature when I had one
when I snorted blow when I was in need I
couldn't sell something can you imagine
me now like now I don't want to [ __ ]
sell out there I'm too embarrassed I'm
happy that you came to the show yeah
how's that yeah I'm just a static that
you paid the 20 to come to the show yeah
nevermind another 30 to 50 and CD boxes
and [ __ ] forks and spoons and
spaghetti sauce you want to buy that
[ __ ]
bite it home on your own time Blaine 70
I'm not full rocker
well I'll put on my striped shirt on and
go out there now and [ __ ] what size
patty there's nothing worse than having
to check an extra bag of just oh and
then you leave the shirts at the club
yeah count 48 and when you get them back
home this 20 that
means every way the slow [ __ ] up to
shirts I was selling the funny I didn't
make I didn't [ __ ] that [ __ ] you I used
to sell shirts to the feature cuz it's
like 500 bucks he got a so that's what I
totally get it but I remember I was
meddling for Bert Kreischer like many
years ago and uh I opened my merch bag
of t-shirts and he put a gay porno did
yeah he just any peek behind was just so
we could see me do it and I turned
around you started laughing I was like
that's pretty funny
I would if I was a feature act in
today's market I had so coke after the
[ __ ] show they left yeah because it's
just a brutal yeah it's just really hard
and I get part of it I guys the [ __ ]
I still in the featuring for 350 a week
there's some Club still pay their hotel
some clubs 350 router hotel now okay 50
without all some probably I'm sure I
used to get there was something there
was a chain I'm not gonna say they are
nice people they're nice people are
still around helped a lot of calm
because if you it depends how you look
at it now it depends how you look at it
if you're looking at it well although
Jews they ripped me off no they didn't
they gave you an opportunity man to
become the comic you are today how you
treated that was up to you
mmm-hmm you know you can't get mad those
people you know what a lot of young
comics do though I've see and I was one
of them it's like you're getting paid
ship you can drink for free so you get
[ __ ] ripped you like [ __ ] you know
I'll make my money back with alcohol
biggest mistake I made
how are you know you still drinkin I'm
Way better I don't show doubt
significantly cuz I had to man all the
morning flights all the press all the
travel it's like my back [ __ ] hurts
already I got it I got a I don't want to
feel like [ __ ] every day
when I'm special yet released it came
out February 10th without parole it's
been out for yes but now for almost two
weeks
how's it doing it's you know last I
checked it's pushing 800,000 views on
YouTube and I'm pretty happy with that I
hope it keeps moving forward and you
know I did this one this way just
because you know the last ones Justine
get views the way I hope they would and
it's you put so much work into these
specials and then for them it almost
feels like sometimes you get a certain
amount of money and it's like a bribe so
they'll never be seen you know and and I
need its and it's so [ __ ] up you're
like are you well you'll get paid but
it's gonna be buried on some [ __ ]
weird website and no one's gonna see it
like Comedy Central's last one and add
every three minutes like who can sit
through that I can't sit through that
you know so this one was like the one
rule was like no ads I need people to
watch this I'm proud of this I worked
hard on it I shot this myself because no
one wanted to make it so let me let me
let me make sure at least get seen you
know it's probably central border from
you they did up for YouTube only so for
YouTube they they put it up so I I
figured they'd have a big subscription
base they push it like it was an hour
special and post about it and stuff and
and I think that definitely helps so I'm
grateful that they they helped and
bought it and and they did it the way I
want to do it what's going on with you
NYX my NYX isn't playing badly they
traded my favorite player to the
Clippers Marcus Morris
I love MOOC it's so crazy how I'm so a
little loop and I'm ashamed you don't be
because it's been tough this is the time
to be a comeback in a few years but I'll
let you know when to come back funny
when I see Rappaport I follow Rappaport
on Twitter yeah and he [ __ ] about the
next constantly and I don't know I I
bitching about the next to me is like
bitching about the president I still
you're not supposed to [ __ ] about the
price the United States only now do
people get to open their mouths every
[ __ ] day
well that was growing up in New York
City you know [ __ ] about the next you
went home you shut your [ __ ] mouth
and you'd better be getting it and like
you said you prayed to God that they
didn't put Phil Jackson in the fourth
floor cuz that's what I would just hang
up the phone and rip up my little
gambling ticket office and you need city
in bet like three of us about 25 bucks
yeah you know oh yeah
I still remember uh Glen ganja Zach yeah
do you remember going down Lincoln High
music wasn't Nick he was a white guy he
went to UNLV yeah he was great at you
and I'll be here look at see what he is
going on just played just what it was
like the 70s 80s it was huh for college
even though he played for the Knicks
what year is he playing for the Knicks
going on does it was a white dude yeah
everything's great great play like just
the basic white guy what do you expect
from a six before white guy stroke at
spot 20s here and get the ball across
the [ __ ] thing and give it to the
power of the team and Glen played four
years he played that you and I'll be
against one of my favorite players of
all time a guy named Michael Coren he
played for North Carolina he's from
Jersey City hmm and they will have to be
in that for years and God knows what
else but uh what does it say that I
think Robert Colorado yeah he grew up in
Boulder Colorado
no [ __ ] everybody don't all your cities
man yeah he grew up in Boulder but mm
when I got the boulder then you get the
bigger picture the Gondry's exit like a
[ __ ] family of jacked and bold to
everybody knew they were damned they had
a younger brother the younger brother
was better than Glen but he ended up
going to Phoenix which Walker Davis and
they uncovered late this big cocaine
ring and Phoenix Walter though he had a
he had a bird but whatever Walter Davis
was tremendous a tremendous basketball
player didn't plan he D always an
all-star Glen John Jake's brother was
down anything I caught up in a coke
stick
Jesus and then that career Bajaj music
when that play for the Knicks was only
two years 77 necessarily not yen will be
the average like like eight points if I
was lucky but he was one of those white
dudes that just was perfect for New York
he could only dollar bill Brad
yeah it is perfect for New York dollar
bill man I read about something out a
dollar bill Bradley in a practice I
think Cazzie Russell who is you know the
sixth man and the Knicks he got pulled
over just like driving and while being
black in Michigan and it was like a
whole thing in practice and you know he
just started [ __ ] with like you know
dollar bill maybe some of the other
white players in the team in Willis Reed
was like you [ __ ] hit him again
you're gonna have to go through me like
kind of his way being like he ain't the
problem you know what I mean he's your
guy we're a team you know like Willis
Reed just [ __ ] lead he was just a
leader man such a badass yeah what
happened cuz he had a good yeah good
career ooh
Glenn oh he he averaged 14 points three
386 three-point percentage
oh nice yeah that was a weird time for
the Knicks oh that was when they were
kind of like windows 77 to 79 and then
like 85 have you retired and we got you
a an 86 3 he retired not for a little
somebody Debra and then he [ __ ] tried
to shoot himself with a 22 is he missed
his heart oh the big joke in the town
was you can make a 20-footer could you
missed the [ __ ] heart shot with a 22
[ __ ] oh my god see if so he's alive he's
alive he's a realtor something they all
went to school together him the big-time
Victoria's Secret model the one that
married Harry Connick jr. Jill Goodacre
okay owns half a boulder because there
be office long coke she was buying real
estate her and her father was just every
time she showed her [ __ ] little body
in a bikini boom
she won another house under the park
another parking structure and now Jill
got a KERS probably got tons more money
in the Harry Connick jr. tan but yet
claims a lot of Glen colleges it was a
nick oh I used to go to all those game
Michael Ray Richardson yeah
he's dead huh he passed away who Glen
yeah what did he pass away 2009 yeah the
Knicks in the 80s man I mean that's they
were kind of
just and then they got Ewing in 86 and
they kind of started gettin aid like
[ __ ] I mean this is like I was born 86
so I I didn't my first real team was
Ewing Oakley Mason Starks Derek Harper
all the [ __ ] beautiful team that's
just as tough as nails we never won but
like I don't mind lose him like that
we were just [ __ ] I mean of course as
a kid it I I was like well surely we'll
win at some point we were this close
every year is last time they won 72 73
that's that's it Walt Frazier calls a
game he's the last time man he I met him
a few times at games I even interviewed
him once where I used to have a sports
show on MSG the Knicks Network and I
interviewed him he was such a good dude
he was like the nicest guy and really
did not expect me to know anything about
him in detail kiss of course they edited
it for every question to be like so
what's it what's it like broadcasting
but I'm like no I'm asking all player
questions like the guy used to share a
[ __ ] room with Phil Jackson on the
road they'd share hotel rooms they
[ __ ] brought the city together when
it's like like a mixed race team winning
championships it's kind of beautiful man
and they really just kind of made it a
born interview when we had I thought
pretty amazing conversation it was
amazing Mickey ever met I mean I [ __ ]
loved John Starks I really did as a kid
he was every kid's favorite cuz he was
unpredictable and he was a gunslinger
Starks was pretty cool man but you know
I shot a commercial with Oakley once and
he was so [ __ ] like intimidating
Oakley was like everything I loved about
basketball he's just like the [ __ ]
he'd [ __ ] take a bullet for anyone on
his team I loved it I was more Bernard
King I met him I interviewed him for my
show great guy great guy I was a Bernard
King type of guy but I'm as a kid
playing basketball and going to make
games and watching yeah you know unless
you're really into basketball and you're
into defenses the science of it when you
watched Walt Frazier and arrow the Pearl
yeah there was something about those two
and they work together they know how to
steal the ball for me they would trap
you at different situations you didn't
know when you're gonna trap this is when
you can
shorts Walt Frazier did know how to hold
you short they were hand checking was a
lot yeah so they would put their hand on
you but one finger one inside your
shorts and you made but you made sure
that guy didn't pull away from you
because then the ref would see the
elastic it was a complete different
heart dam people will never understand
was hand checking the art of hand
checking
yeah he wants to go right you're gonna
make him go left with your hand yeah you
watch old Julius Irving footage today
Julius Erving when it got called with 20
offensive fouls Julius Erving strick was
a hook yeah he would hope you waste and
he would get that first step on you and
then push you off the hook and you need
what kind of crumble they have allowed
today that was a different game and Walt
Frazier and Earl they would keep you at
that arm's distance force you into the
middle they would force you to spin and
Earl would be there the [ __ ] pick
your pocket or they'd vice-versa long
would be than a picnic by the balls
always that corn mash is something that
you know it was an honor
yeah to grow up in New York in those
days like I consider my tenure in New
York like I tell people from North
Bergen New Jersey when you see me walk
and talk you've seen New York in that I
felt that the second I walked in my went
to the Macy's parade yeah hot dog we
catch a ball and threw it away no I
[ __ ] play three-card Monte I was with
a friend of mine who got this next stuck
in the [ __ ] perv show that runs up to
you you don't really flashy like that
right City to club yeah rats got beat up
at Central Park at a river
the little water people have no idea how
much I knew that city with my hand
inside out and when I was fortunate
enough to get a job they had 21 at 52nd
and 7th I would get let out into the
city at 1:00 a.m. from smut Tuesday
to Saturday at 1:00 a.m. you have no
idea what that city was like in 1984 now
that I have one o'clock it was a
constant party mr. Nixon won oh Jesus
you caught the tail end of the [ __ ]
parties I mean it was just uh just
different when our King partied I heard
I mean he drank he drank and snorted
coke they caught him in Jericho came
over shirt then they traded him Santa
Golden State and he got it together he
became the Comeback Player of the Year
and he went back to New York and there
was one week when he scored 62 times
that yeah 60 once against bird I think
once he went off and uh yeah man he was
a badass and he was also [ __ ] cool
like he was just nice man like those did
he wrote a book about having like an
addiction problem and like how shitty
got Hubie Brown was just a [ __ ]
[ __ ] to him as a young player it's
like I think about that like that dude
was abusive and like you know he just he
was a badass if it weren't for injuries
like there was no stopping him was it
different city back then my friend yeah
still a great city I got to go back in
two weeks I got to tell you I'm kind of
excited it's gonna be great going home
it's just a week but it'll work but
listen anytime you want to stop it that
means a lot of special it's cold I got
this and this [ __ ] yeah that's what
everyone says see when your self
produces special they say you got this
but they don't mean it
they're just being nice they're trying
to be encouraging because they know that
you might be making a dumb decision but
it seems to be working all right
where you living now New York I'm Upper
West Side right now 66th Street what do
you think I love it man it's quiet it's
you know it's I mean it's great it's
just like it's my only thing for this
place I was before that I was on 108 and
I love that too I just wanted to be a
little closer anytime I could be a
little closer to the comedy show so I
choose where I live so uh I like the
area of 108 a little better was a little
more like neighborhood E and I kinda I
like the vibe a little better
but uh I mean I love it it's I I miss a
24-hour grocery place I like to I like
to grocery shop at 3:00 a.m. that's my
move
no one's in there it's quiet it's nice
peaceful he throwing you throwing some
tunes you walk around you grab an
avocado you get some cookies it's nice
listen man it's great to have your
studio it was great to be here thank you
man you're doing your thing and you're
on your way up
Thank You Man I wish you nothing but
[ __ ] with success you know you too man
keep killing it hopefully the mix will
turn it around I think I think in a
couple years you know I think you got to
have a healthy level of delusion to be a
sports fan so I got a I got a lot of it
man I'm [ __ ] you know if you look at
through the years I still learn what new
england patriots sucked yes I grew up
the Patriots suck you know Andriy tip it
was all they [ __ ] had then they had
then they got that quarterback drew ya
know for a couple years mister and then
Tom Brady what so killed himself and
that was the end of that [ __ ] you know
people about 12 or 20 years ago when I
came in The Laugh Factory was down his
club I'm the [ __ ] strip yeah laughs
factory that you can't have a decent
bingo game in there the Comedy Store you
know years ago so we shipped things
shipped you know OS 20 years ago 30
years ago they showed you two weeks ago
the liner is where the King was 30 years
ago Joe Montana was the king something
happened it takes a while then a while
to rebuild your legs back in then you're
there again sometimes we don't see him
come in Kansas City
it's not like they were [ __ ] the last
eight years never been in the playoffs
straight we didn't see him coming so
that's a good thing about watching
sports and even with comedy yeah you
know we're trying like I said it's it's
not the it's the little moral victories
that add up and once you have 20 moral
victories
that's when you're ready to attack yeah
little thing Sinatra fell off for a
while [ __ ] here let's you let the fall
off yeah and then you come back that
makes you stronger
yeah and makes you [ __ ] stronger you
got any date you want to promote brother
yeah well my I'm gonna be at the West
mm5 February 29th I'll be at the Royal
Oak comedy castle March 5th through 7th
Gotham in New York City
March 19th through 21st and the
following weekend I'll be in a the
Charlotte comedy zone your bad
[ __ ] high will be at Treasure
Island Friday night
Viva [ __ ] Las Vegas with my boy
Dean del Rizzi tickets are still
available knock yourself out
Friday night Treasure Island and I don't
have a date again till March 27th at the
Arlington theatre up in the Santa
Barbara real quick
the church is brought to you by me
undies listen unless have you been
living under a rock you've heard about
me undies they're going for the total
undies nomination and they won't stop to
every pot Kent listener is wearing one
of these things I've been [ __ ]
singing their praises for years my
drawers I [ __ ] packed why because
they're comfortable then like they're
soft and they keep your balls nice and
dry they figured out the secret of
softness Micro Modell fabric you're
gonna love this drug it's made from
trees it's sustainable it's stretchy
yet firm nice and cozy it keeps your
nuts nice like Bikram you visited Bikram
documentary ha ha the way that [ __ ]
guy wore those little panties look at
his little hindu nuts tight to his
[ __ ] thing yeah it stays smooth
especially after multiple watches Plus
me undies is [ __ ] everything socks
loungewear joggers robes slippers even
baby clothes
personally I'm into all I'm into all the
joggers because you know how much uncle
Joey loves [ __ ] comfort and these
things are comfortable as [ __ ] speaking
of love me undies are showing you love
with the killer [ __ ] awful for the
church family you ready grab a pen go to
me on these right now
pick something [ __ ] but go with the
joggers you're gonna love them you're
gonna get 15% off and free shipping on
your first purchase
who takes care you like that on the
Monday morning it's called
you need some new underwear enough with
that those
white [ __ ] candy white underwear from
1960 you take your pants off for Chitina
laughter you you show up on me undies
they know you're ready to sling dick
understanding so go to me on these right
now go calm slash Joey and get 15% off
and free shipping on your first purchase
plus you get me on these 100%
satisfaction guarantee
that's 15% off free shipping and a
hundred-percent money-back guarantee
supported me on these dot-com / Joey
right now cut this [ __ ] and slip into
something a little bit more comfortable
I want to thank my man Sam Burrell Thank
You Man I want to thank the
[ __ ] coming in every day
thank you mother for one of the things
Joey I forgot to say I actually have a
basketball podcast called pod don't lie
which is it's on iTunes and it's uh it's
only basketball so if you like
basketball
there's you know all mba call mba pod
don't lie with my buddy Stavros it's
it's a ton of fun it's so College we
only do MBA but it'sit's fun as hell man
and no this is fun is a lot of fun
talking you guys today
[ __ ] I'm happy you came up I really
up I'm surprised you didn't come on with
a buttered roll treasurer on Friday
night I'll see you guys Wednesday
morning
tip top Magoo ready to go I love your
concept to stay black have a great
weekend have a great week
what the [ __ ] am I saying